Matt Kurt Russell or Richard Dean
Anderson as a fan as a fan I would
always pick RDA
because he has played the role for way
longer and the the character was
expanded because of him the only problem
I can see or one of the big problems I
can see is in the script uh Jack dies
yeah so no matter so if Richard D
Lansing plays it that's a nice send-off
for his character but if Kurt Russell
plays it it means we're never going to
see Richard Dean Hanson again I think it
would have been a really nice goodbye to
Richard Dean Anderson I think it was
well if he's gonna die in the film
anyway why why wouldn't RDA come back
and playing well and thinking about it I
guess as an executive from Amazon they
are trying to cut costs in a lot of ways
Kurt Russell's a lot more expensive than
RDA and you do have a solidified base of
people that will know that will go to
that theater no matter what if RDA is
there